Most of AliExpress mobile users are Android users
Our Android app has over 50 million downloads globally
We have users from over 200 countries
Our main buyer markets include United States, Russia, Spain and France
It is one of the most popular shopping apps in over 20 countries
We are also a Top Developer on Google Play
We implemented Google Sign-In last year
it allows users to sign into AliExpress with their Google account
Now over 10% of our users use Google Sign-In
more than any other 3rd party sign in feature that we offer
We also recently implemented the smart-lock feature
it allows users to save their password
and use their saved password to sign in
We continued to see positive feedback from users
so we progressed to allowing users to sign in automatically
when they open our app
After we implemented smart-lock
our sign-in success rate increased from 84% to 92%
We realized early on that the material design makes it easier
for our Android users to navigate the app
So in early 2015, our app went through a significant design change
to make sure we are fully compliant with the Material Design guidelines
After the update, we received a lot of 5-star user reviews praising our design
and our user rating improved to 4.46
Many mobile users of Alibaba Group are Android users
We have reaped enormous benefits
in terms of user engagement
by leveraging the unique features offered by Android
We recently previewed the upcoming Android N
and are very excited about features like multi-window mode
And we will try our best to implement them as fast as possible
to further improve our customer experience